ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
สวัสดีทุกคนนะคะวิ่ง
[เพลง]
ไปขึ้นที่สองสำหรับสัปดาห์นี้นะคะใช่ค่ะ
เราวันที่ก่อนครูฟ้าวันที่ว่าวันนี้วัน
วันอะไรคะถูกฟ้าวันนี้วันวันๆหัดวัน
พฤหัสบดีนะคะอะวันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพฤหัสที่
16 ค่ะ 16 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมปีพตต
เท่าไหร่คะ 2564 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ 2  e02  1
5 วันนี้วันพฤหัสวันที่ 16 นะคะ 10  10
เดือนธันวาคมนะคะรู้ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลา 4 โมงค่ะ 04:47
จุดศูนย์นะคะเราก็จะพูดพูดจนถึงเวลากี่
โมงคะ
16:30 น
16:30 นนะคะ
ที่แล้วคลิปที่แล้วนะคะคุณ
คลิปที่แล้ว
ครูฟ้ากับครูเอ๋พูดเกี่ยวกับอะไรนะคะคลิป
ที่แล้วครูป๊ากับครูเอกพูดเกี่ยวกับผัก
และผลไม้ค่ะขาดและผลไม้นะคะอ้า
โอนี่โอเค
เนื้อสัตว์และผลไม้อาหารๆขัดและผลไม้การ
ท่านๆๆหรือผลไม้อะนี้คิดใช่ไหมอันนี้ผัก
และผลไม้
อ่านคลิปนี้ก็ยังอยู่ที่ผักและผลไม้
ดูอะ
ผลไม้ที่อันนี้กล้วยกล้วยนะคะด้วยครู 5
คู่ฟ้ากินกล้วยใช่ไหมคะกินหะกูฟ้าชอบกิน
กล้วยอะกล้วยน่ะรวยจะมีอยู่นะหนึ่งหวี
เราก็ต้องทำอะไรคะดึงดื่มหรือใช้มีดตัด
คุณฟ้าดึงดึงนะดึงหมุนนึงนะดึงดึงตึงได้
นะคะเก่งได้อ่ะพอดึงแล้วกินได้เลยไหมคะก็
ไม่ได้ทำไมอ่ะกล้วยเนี่ยต้องกรอกปลอก
เปลือกใครเมตรไหมคะมือค่ะ
มือ
โอเคมือแล้วจับที่ตรงไหน
กับ
ขั้วหรือก้นกับก้นคน
แต่ละก็เอามือจับก้นแล้วก็ที่ขั้วไม่ใช่
เหรออย่างนี้หรอ
อ๋อกูไปทำอย่างนี้นะคะใช่ค่ะคู๋ทำอย่าง
นี้
นักเรียนทำยังไง
อ่าจับจับตรง
ต้องก้นแล้วก็ค่ะคั่วหรือจับตรงขั้วแล้ว
หักก้นฮ่าๆกูฟ้าบอกว่าหักไม่ใช่ไหมคะ
ดึงใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ดึงลงมา
ดึงลงมา
มาดีอะไรคะภูฟ้าดึงเปลือกช้ำเพราะมันจะ
แพทย์เร่งเปลือกลงแล้วมา
หลังกัดกินได้แล้วก็กินได้อร่อยไหมอ่ะ
นั่งติดคุยอร่อยคุยต้องกินไหมกินไหมล่ะ
หรืออยากกินไหมคุยกูเองไม่ชอบกูด้วยกิน
ได้กูเองไม่ชอบไปกินได้
x กัดนะคะ
[เพลง]
ข้างในก็สีเหลืองก็
หวาน
ๆหวานหอมนิดหน่อยเอ้อ
อัน Point กินข้าวเหรอถึงกูอันนี้กล้วย
ออร์แกนิคนะคะดิบ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋
จะพอแล้วนะอันนี้ก็เหลือกรวยนะคะอันนี้ก็
เป็นเนื้อของกล้วยนะคะลูกเวลากินกล้วยไม่
ต้องใช้มีดเพราะแกะใช่มะแกะออกปะแล้วบอก
ว่าแกะเปลือกแล้วก็กรอกใช่มั้ยหรอกปอ
เปลือกเปลือก
เปลือกปอกเลยอ่ะใช้มือต่อ Strong กลับไป
มีอะไรอีกดี
อันนี้ดีกว่า
คุยหากันสีม่วงสีม่วงคู่ป่าอุ้ยอันนี้
อะไรคะตัวเององุ่น
อ่าอันหมุนนะคะนักเรียนพลเวลาจะกินองุ่น
ทำยังไงอ่ะ
เวลาที่ไปไหม
ได้ไหมอาจจะทำมีอันหมดแล้วก็จัด
ได้ไหมใครบ้าง
เปรี้ยว
เด็ดค่ะดึงผ่านดึง
ดึงนะคะแล้วก็กินนะคะ
ฟ้า
อาหนอันเนี้ย
เหมือนกล้วย
ก็คือข้างใน
ไม่มีเม็ด
ไม่มีเม็ดไม่มีเลยไม่มีเห็นไหมคะนักเรียน
ไม่มีเม้นท์อันนี้ก็ไม่ใช่นะเม็ดมันไม่
ใช่นักเรียนกินได้อือก็ต้องปอกเปลือกไหม
คะหุ่นอนุมูลอันนี้เล็กๆเปลือกกินได้นะคะ
เปลือกกินได้ว่ามาจากเป็นออร์แกนิคฟาร์ม
กินได้ไม่มีเคมีกินได้
แต่กูฟ้าต่อคะออกเกลือ
เล็กๆนะ
บอกได้ค่ะคุณฟ้าบอกนะเกลือ
อย่าเปลือก
หลับได้
แต่แต่ถ้าถ้าเป็นองุ่นใหญ่ครูเอ๋ปลอก
เปลือกฮาๆๆๆอ่ะ
สิง่วง
นี่ลืมซิมกระบอกเปลือกองุ่นเปลี่ยนสี
เป็นสีเขียวใช่เปลือกสีม่วงเสื้อข้างในสี
เขียวนะคะมากเป็นคู่เองไม่ปอกคู๋เด้งแล้ว
ก็กินเลย
[เพลง]
ไปให้ผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวกูไปหาก่อนองุ่นเนี่ย
ไม่มีเมตรไม่มีเมล็ดขอโทษค่ะรู้เอ้ยก็ไม่
มีเมล็ดนะคะถ้าองุ่นใหญ่ๆจะมีเมล็ดนะคะ
เก็บองุ่นนะอ้าๆมีไออีกครูเอ๋มี
ลำไย
จะกินต้องต้องต้องเด็ดก่อนเนาะเด็ดเด็ด
เลข 1
ติดลำไยเด็กหาเด็กหากินได้เลยไหมคะ R กิน
ไม่ได้น้องต่อเกลือนะคะท่าเรือก่อนเองออก
นะ
ใช้มือเลยเนาะมือไหมใช้ใช้เล็บก็ได้ใช้
มีดเลยได้กูบ้านที่นี่ไหมคะไม่รู้ว่าใช้
เล็บ
เล็บแบบต้องปอกเปลือกปอกเปลือกโอเคกู ah
I  love  Beach แฮปปี้
คุณฟ้าอะไรคะอุ้ยสวย
ลำใหญ่นะคะคือนี่ลำไยลัยลำไย
เปลือกสีน้ำตาลเนื้อสีอะไรคะเนื้อสีขาว
ค่ะขาวนิ่มๆนะคะคุยกินเนาะได้อ้ะว่า
[เพลง]
เอา
หมูมาลำไยมีอะไรเข้าก็ฟ้านิลำไยมีเม็ดสี
อะไรคะสีดำค่ะ
มีเม็ดเม็ดใหญ่นะคะเม็ดใหญ่สีดำ
กุมภาชอบไหมสีฟ้าชอบกินลำใหญ่ชอบกินลำไย
นักเรียนชอบกันใหญ่ไหมฮะ
ไม่ได้ชอบนะคิดว่านะชอบอ่ะกูอีกว่าเก็บ
ก่อนนะคะหนูได้ค่ะ
ต่อไปโอเคครูเอกก็นี่
อะไรนะคะ
อันนี้คือส้มส้มนะคะส้มเนี่ยยังมีเปลือก
กินได้ไหมตัดเลยเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้หรอกมีแต่ให้ทำยังไงส้มป้อง
ออกเปลือกก่อนเอ้อต่อเปลือกนะคะงั้นคุย
บอก
ใช้เล็บใช่ไหมคะไม่ต้องชีวิตใครมีมั้ยไม่
ๆไม่ต้องนะแบบเลยอ่ะในคุยป้อมเปลือกยังไง
อย่างที่ก้นอยู่ที่หมดบางทีที่ขั้วหรือ
ที่ก้นก็ได้กูฟ้าเวลาคุณฟ้าปอกเปลือกส้ม
ที่ขั้วไปที่ก้นขอดูก้นหน่อยก้น
แล้วคั่วล่ะขั้ว
ข้นค่ะข้นใช่มั้ยอ้ะที่ก้นใช้เล็บติดเข้า
ไปแล้วค่ะ
อ่ะ
เปลือกอ่าดึงเปลือกออกมาปลอกเหลืองๆๆเนาะ
ๆๆกล้วยลำไย
เอาองุ่น
หลอกง่ายๆ
ขอ
เรือส้มหอ
หอหอ
อร่อยอร่อยไหมนะไม่รู้ยังไม่ได้กิน
วันนี้ที่ฟาร์มส่งมา
โอเคครูฟ้า
ที่ส้มมีตรงนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรนะใหญ่เนาะ
ใหญ่หักสีขาวๆคือใหญ่ใหญ่ส้มใหญ่ส้ม
ครูฟ้ากินไหมคะกินค่ะกินนะคะกินกูฟ้าไหม
ดึงออกใช่ไหมไม่ดึงไม่ดึง
ครูเอ๋ชอบดึงอ้าวทำไมอ่ะ
จริงๆไม่ดุอุ้ยดีกว่าว่าใหญ่ส้มเบ
ไวตามินซีมากๆ 8 คู่เอกคิดไม่สวยเคยเห็น
ดึง
คู๋ชอบดึงออก
ดึง 50% ก็ได้เนาะ
แล้วก็ส้ม 1 ลูกข้างในก็จะมีส้มเป็นเลข
ว่าเป็นอะไรนะเป็นเป็นกี่ๆ 2  3  4  5
7  8  9  10  11  12 ข้างในมีส้ม
12 กลีบนะคะ
ครูฟ้าขา 5 แกะและคะอุ้ยแกะส้มแล้วนะดึง
ยายออกแล้ว
เราก็เดี๋ยวกูเอกใช่นี่นะคะ
มีอันนี้กินได้เลยหรือยังเลิกกินได้แล้ว
ค่ะได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะกินหญ้าแต่ว่านาย
111 กรีดน่ะค่ะคุณฟ้าบางซึ่งจะมีอันนี้
ค่ะเห็นไหมคะ
เม็ดชายมีเมะหรือเมล็ดนะคะอ้าพูดเม็ดก็
ได้พูดเมล็ดก็ได้นะคะ
นี่มีมีเมล็ดส้ม
ต้องเอาออกให้เห็นไหมเห็นไหมเห็นไหม
โอเคอ่าให้ดู
เห็นไหมคะเมล็ดนะเมล็ด 5 ก็เข้า
ข้างในจะเป็นแบบนี้เนาะ
อร่อย
ใช่อร่อยๆ
เบรคไปเชียวไม่ยายไม่ได้หรอก็ไม่ได้ครู
เอ๋สอนก็ไม่ได้หรอไม่ได้
โอเคกินหลายอย่าง
เก็บส้ม
ส้มเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆๆ
อย่างมะนาวเนี่ยมะนาวเปรี้ยวใช่ไหมคะ
เดียว
ลำไย
ลำไยหวาน
ส้มเนี้ย
เรี่ยวหวานรวมกัน
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆนะคะโอเคมี
อะไรอีกแล้วก็เอกดูไหนคลีอะไรที่แกะได้
ได้อันนี้แกะไม่ได้อะไรอ่ะพุทธศาสตร์ทำไม
แกะไม่ได้คะครูเอ๋
แกะไม่ได้เปลือกไม่ออกเออ
เปลือกไม่นี่ใครเนี้ยแกะแล้วเปลือกไม่ออก
น้องใช้มีดของฉันนี่แบบผู้ชา
ยอ่ะกินได้ครูฟ้าอ่ะใช้มีดโอเคกัดโอเค
เดี๋ยวคู่เอกจะใช้มีดนะคะหั่นได้ค่ะ
shop ไหมอุ้ย
ข้างในสีขาว
เหมือนแอปเปิ้ล
หลอก
ได้ยินเสียงไหม
คล่อง
หวาน
แล้วคนอื่นจะให้ดู
ข้างในมีเม็ดตามี S  E นี่เม็ดพุทราแบ่ง
เม็ด
หนึ่งไหม
ซองแล้ว
ส้มนี่มีมีเม็ดมากๆนะ 1 กลีบบ้านจะมี 1
เม็ด
2 เม็ดนะคะ
[เพลง]
มีหลายๆเม็ดๆลำใยมี 1 เม็ด
พุทรามี 1 เม็ดนะคะอ่ะเก็บก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะ
เสียดาย
กล้วยไม่มีลูกไม่มีเม็ดอ้ะฮิเมะกล้วยไม่
มิดเนี่ยเอาไปครูเอ๋มีอะไรอีกคะ
ครูฟ้ากูฟ้าอยากให้ครูเอ๋อ่ะ f
มะละกอวิ
กะเลยเลยนะคะกินเลยอ่ะเฮ้ยเฮ้ย
พี่เพิ่งกัดไม่ได้ต้องใช้หนี้ต
ได้คุยกับผอเอาทิชชูเอานี้ทิ้งก่อน
มีที่ทุกวางก่อนนะ
กินโชว์วางต้องมีทิชชู่วางมารับก่อนแล้ว
ก็มี
แล้วก็
ทำอะไรคู๋จะ
หันมาก่อน
ไม่หันม่ายฮือนิ่ม
รู้ป๊าคลิปมะละกอมีเมล็ดไหม
มีค่ะมินึงสองสามสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดแปด
เก้าสิบ
เยอะๆมีมากๆก็มีเยอะๆเดี๋ยวมาดูกันนะคะ
ฉันมะละกอนะคะที่แล้วก่อนใช้ไม่
กลัวมากเลยอ๋อ
โอ้ยมีเมล็ดเยอะมากขอ
คุยว่าไง 1 อันกินอะไรได้มั้ยคะกินเลยค่ะ
วันที่ทำมีช้อนแล้ว
หือเป็นโอคาโด้ใช่แต่ว่ามันใช่เราไม่ตัด
อันนี้คุยใสที่นี่ล่ะ
นะไม่ตัดก็
ทำแบบนี้นะคะเคยไม่ถุงนะคะ
เราก็เอามันเล็บนกเวลามีมีเม็ดเยอะๆอย่าง
เงี้ยคือคนไทยเกาะเสม็ดก็ได้นะคะแต่ว่า
เยอะๆก็จะพูดมันเล็กอ่ะเอามาเล่นออกเอา
มีดเขียนอย่างเงี้ยอะ
มิเขียวมา
กีฬา
เนี่ยมันเขี่ยเมล็ดออก
เยอะเห็นไหมนักเรียนเยอะ
แม่
[เพลง]
เอกก็เอามาเล่นต่อก่อนนะคะเอาออกให้หมดนะ
ก็ออกให้หมดใช่นี่
โง่จริงๆ
ไม่ไปไหนจะ
เสร็จแล้วเอกเวลากินบางคนต่อเปลือกแบบนี้
แบบครูเอก Shop ฉันแบบนี้
แล้วจะทำยังไงต่อมาแล้วเหตุผลๆยังมีมี
เม็ดนี่เอาไม่ออกอ่ะเอามาเล็กออกให้หมด
เพราะมันจะไม่อร่อยจะกินมรึง
นี่
ค่ะ
แล้วก็หันตรงนี้ออกมา
ที่นี่ค่ะป๊าทำแบบนอบเลือกแล้วคะออก
เปลือก
นี้
น้อง
ไงเกี่ยวต่อเปลือกง่ายๆ
แล้วก็หัน
โอเคเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็กินกินได้เลยหือกิน
ยังไงคะครูเอ๋
หวาน
หวานอ่ะ
หญ้าหวานมาก
นักเรียนโอเคไหมโทรหาบ้าง
คืออร่อยมาก
มารักกันบ้านคุณแม่ครูเอ๋
อร่อยยิ่งมันเกินไปดูคลิป Daily  lives
มะละกอได้นะคะเดี๋ยวนี้ Life
vest เก็บมะละกอนะคะแปลยังมีอีกหนึ่งใช่
ไหมครูเฟิร์ส
มีอะไรคะมะพร้าว
เอาเอามะพร้าวจะกินได้ไหม
ครูเอกจะทำยังไง
ไม่มีมี่เล็กๆมีเล็กๆโอเคไหมมะพร้าวไม่
โอเคคุยแบบไม่มีวิ่งไม่ติดใหญ่ๆโอ้โห
เรียกว่ามีดอะไรครับผมฟ้ามีอีโต้ค่ะมี
mgtow นะคะอ่ะอ่า
อันนี้แบบใจดีนะคะแต่เขาเรียกว่าต้อง Shop
กูฟ้าคิดว่ากูเอกจะหลอกมะพร้าวได้ไหม
ได้
ไม่มีสับลงไปแล้วก็งะงานออกมา
อุ้ยเอาเปลือกออก
ออกมาฟ้าวนะครับเปาะเลือกใช่ไหมคะเรียกมา
เทียบขอบเปลือกปอก The  Army สัก
คอมพิวเตอร์จะทำปุ๋ย
ได้ยินเสียงไหมคะคิดหน่อย
อุ้ยโอโห
มือกลัวมือ
โอเค
แล้ว
โอ้ยอันนี้ไม่ง่ายๆใช่ไหม
อามาด้วยยากกล้วยเนี่ยต่อเปลือกง่ายๆ
ร้าวไม่ง่าย
เอาเกลียดออกนะคะ
ระวังมือนะ
ระหว่างโต๊ะถึง
ระวังโต๊ะ
ได้กลัวโดนมือเหมือนกันอ่ะโอเค
ปอกอยู่นะคะเสร็จแล้วเห็นไหม
แล้วกินได้เลยหรอจริงยังไม่ได้ต้อง Shop
ก่อนเวลาจะต้องเอาเปลือกออกนะคะเอกตรงนี้
แล้วกันสำหรับนี้แหละโอ๊ะ
ค่ะใช้สันมีดนะคะฝันใช้คมมีดคมมีดจะได้
ค่ะเสร็จแล้ว
ภาพเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นเกิดว่าน้ำมะพร้าวไปโดนคอมพิวเตอร์
น้ำขาวของที่ถ้าคุยเสียมั้ยไม่รู้คุยไม่
เสีย
ค่าครูเอกจะเป็นอะไรไหมมายๆเดี๋ยวนะคะครู
เอกเทศก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
มีน้ำมาก็ต้องมีทิชชู่แล้วก็เช็ดเนาะ
กระดาษทิชชู่แล้วก็คิดเครียดๆหน้า
หันมาทางคอมพิวเตอร์
ติดในแล้วน่าจะ
น้ำเป็นคอมพิวเตอร์เลยค่ะงั้นกูเอกก็จะทำ
วีดีโอไม่ได้นะคะเพราะกับเธอเสมอคะ
เปิดค่ะเปิด
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋พรุ่งนี้
ใช่ไหมหาเขาเรียกว่าอะไรอ้ะฝาป๋า
ป๋าเดี๋ยวนะคะผัว 6 กูไอ้เอาอันนี้มา
ฝากเอาชาหมัก
มาแล้วระหว่าง
[เพลง]
โอเคเมื่อ
ว่ามะพร้าวเนี่ยมีน้ำมะพร้าวเนาะขนาดนี้
มะพร้าวอ่อนจึงมีน้ำมะพร้าวเราจะกินน้ำ
มะพร้าวต้องมีหลอด
ครีมมีหลอดนี้หลอดหลอดแล้วก็เอาหลอดใส่ลง
ไป
นะคะคะแล้วก็ดูดค่ะ
รสชาติเป็นยังไง
หวานๆเปรี้ยวนิดหน่อย
คู๋หิวน้ำอือ
วันๆริ้วเปรี้ยวๆๆรูปฟ้ารู้ไหมตรงนี้กิน
ได้นะคะ
กินยา
God ใช้เปลือกมะพร้าว
ลาก็
เราเรียกว่าอะไรนะป่ะใช่มั้ยแงะเนี้ย
ก็ได้ไงเข้าไป
อันนี้คือเนื้อนะคะเนื้อมะพร้าว
ท่านี้มีอะไรคะตลาดเนาะมาหาฝาตรงเนี้ยดัก
เอาออกมาก็เป็นฝาแต่จริงๆเรียกว่ากะลา
หน้ากะลาอันนี้เนื้อ
แล้วครูเอกก็ดูดน้ำมะพร้าวน้ำมะพร้าว
ข้างในนะคะข้างในรู้เห็นไหมอ่ะ 6 ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวคอมพิวเตอร์
ตู้เขียนคลิปตื่นเต้นนะคะ
คลิปถึงเป็น one  minute
[เพลง]
ตื่นเต้นและไม้เยอะๆผลไม้อันนี้กินให้ดู
นะคะคุณนิสัยมีแล้วกูเองมีอะไรคะเขาก็มี
อันนี้ผลไม้มั้ยฮะ
อะไรอ่ะหมี
อุ้ย
หมีเป็นหมีอะผลไม้รู้ผลแล้วก็ไม่ใช่หมดละ
ไม้
ที่ไหนมันผลไม้เฮ้ยเป็นขนม
เค้ก
อันนี้ไม่ต้องแกะอันนี้เปิดไม่เปิด
เปิดแล้วไม่มีเปิดเปิดแล้วก็มีซอสมีช้อน
แล้วก็ตัดแล้วก็กินได้แล้วก็ตัดกินข้าว
ของกูฟ้าของครูฟ้าเป็นขนมของครูเอ๋คะเป็น
ผลไม้นะคะรอเงินแล้วก็คอมพิวเตอร์เปียก
มากๆ
ไม่มีชื่อไหมโอเควันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก
เทคนิคตอบเรือของผลไม้รู้หนักมากผลไม้มี
อะไรมี
มี
มีมันเล็บนะอ่าอะไรไม่มีเมล็ดอย่างรวยไม่
มีเมล็ดมะพร้าวก็ไม่มีเมล็ดนะคะมันไม่มี
ก็เท้ามีแต่เปลือกใช่มั้ยเปลือกกะลาแล้ว
ก็เนื้อเนื้ออยู่ข้างในแล้วก็น้ำ
ขาว
ต้องไปแล้วค่ะเพราะว่าไอ้อ่ะอ่ะ
น้ำเต็มคลองครูเอ๋มีทั้งเปลือกทั้งน้ำตอน
นี้คุณน้องเพชรกรีมาเอมมี่ด้วย
วันนี้ก็สวัสดีนะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
บายค่ะถ้า
พี่ตุ้ยกับ